يعمل فوزي في احدى احياء العاصمه التونسيه
في مجال المطاعم وتقديم الاكلات السريعه
منذ ازيد من 30 عاما يقول ان سنه الحاليه
هي الاصعب بنسبه اليها في ظل الارتفاع
الجنوبي للاسعار المواد الاوليه
والاستهلاكيه
غضبه اصحاب المهن الصغرى من ارتفاع
الاسعار يتقاسممه معهم المواطن الذي وجد
نفسه مضطرا الى الله وراء مواد الطاقه
والوقوف في توابير من اجل تحصيل بعض
المواد الغذائيه المفقوده من المحلات
والاسواق
المعزه فيه الضوء انا ماشيين في التصعيد
فيه شلون يخللونه
تحطه 30 دينار وتروح وما في مشكله
قانون الماليه
[موسيقى]
الاساسيه بنسبه تفوق الثلث وسيشهد دعم
المحروقات تراجعا بالنسبه تفوق الربع
رفضته منظمات المجتمع المدنيه وبررته
الحكومه بالظرفيه الاقتصاديه الصعبه محليا
والوليا
هناك ارتفاع متواصل في كل المواد وفي كل
الخدمات وخاصه بارتفاع عملها ثمن
المحروقات اكيد منها بقيه
المكونات
ترفع منها ترفع في الكلفه وبالتالي هذا
يازم الوضع لشرائح كثيره من المجتمع كنا
نخشى عن الشرائح الضعيفه اليوم حتى شرائح
المتوسطه اصبحت بتبيعه العلم كذلك
وتعمل تونس على تحقيق نسبه نمو في حدود
واحد فاصل ثمانيه بالمئه سنه القادمه عبر
تفعيلي عدد من الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه
والحصول على قرض مالي جديد من صندوق النقد
الدولي
بين نظرتي مواد الطاقه والمواد
الاستهلاكيه وغلاء اسعارها وشح الموارد
الماليه للدوله تتواصلوا معاناه التونسيين
الذين تراجعات قدرتهم شراءيه وسطها
تحضيرات من توتر الوضع الاجتماعي وليد عبد
الله العربيه
تونس